CARTER MORGAN: This week, we're
talking about the Kubernetes
product security committee,
Java 11 for App Engine,
and GKE usage metering.
I'm Carter Morgan, and
welcome to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
When it comes to
open source software,
there's plenty of
work to be done.
That can be both
encouraging and terrifying,
depending on your perspective.
If you're a company
considering Kubernetes
as the core of your
cloud strategy,
this recap of security
investigations
should be a great comfort
to you and your CTO.
It's a great breakdown of how
vulnerabilities are assessed,
investigated, and resolved
by the product security
committee for Kubernetes.
Speaking of resolving things,
Java 11 for App Engine
is now generally available.
So if you've been dreaming of
building modern Java backends,
using modern frameworks,
or simply using
the latest language
features of Java 11,
your dreams have come true.
Also new this week, more
features in BigQuery.
We've added new
scripting and stored
procedures, multiple queries
in a single statement,
simplified the process for
migrating Teradata to BigQuery,
and increased BI
Engine reservations.
These updates bring even
more flexibility, simplicity,
and choice to your
data warehouse.
As always, Google Cloud is
designed to be flexible.
And this means making sure your
Cloud usage fits your needs.
To help out with this,
Google Kubernetes Engine
rolled out Usage Metering
in beta earlier this year.
It's now ready
for anyone to use.
So you can reduce waste thanks
to consumption-based metrics
that allow you to compare and
contrast resource requests
with actual utilization.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
And if you have any
thoughts or ideas,
leave us a comment or tweet us.
I'm Carter Morgan.
And we'll see you in the Cloud.